hey Cinderella and Snow White we heard
the new generation of Disney Princesses
don't want to sit with you
apparently Disney theme parks have a
character hierarchy and princesses like
Elsa Anna and Rapunzel's think they run
the show turns out working at Disney
World isn't all it's cracked up to be
but you and the other princesses are
making kids dreams come true every
single day so in the end it's all worth
it the happiest place on earth isn't
always what it seems at least not for
the employees working at one of the most
demanding theme parks in the world can
have its challenges some cast members
and visitors has even wound up in Disney
Jail yeah you heard right
Disney jail keep watching to get all the
deets frequent attacks Walt Disney theme
parks want to protect their visitors no
matter what which is why the place is
rolling with security but as it turns
out it's the cast members who need the
most protecting young kids and entire
families constantly attacked costumed
characters one time a family was so
upset with Pluto for taking a break if
they push the costume employee into a
fountain while hard to believe attacks
of this magnitude happen all the time at
Disneyland the haunted house Fiasco if
you think that's weird wait until you
hear this one it's extremely common for
guests to bring their beloved family
members to Disney in urns security
guards constantly have to prevent
visitors from using Disney theme parks
as burial grounds if we can't make this
stuff up the most popular place for
guests to dump their late loved ones
ashes is in the haunted mansion but
don't worry
everything gets vacuumed immediately
this issue has gotten so out of hand
that Park visitors have gotten banned
from Disneyland for life welcome to the
Disney family a former Walt Disney World
employee who would rather remain
anonymous gave the Thrillist the lowdown
on what really happens behind the scenes
at Disney World and let's just say it
isn't pretty one of the first steps in
being welcomed into the Disney family is
taking a disney indoctrination course
which can be compared to modern day
brainwashing secondly employees are made
to sign their life away agreeing to work
for as long as disney desires former
cast members have reported working
80-hour weeks in boiling temperatures
without being compensated for overtime
no babies please
while Disney theme parks are built for
children and families alike but oddly
enough most of the cast embers don't
like dealing with babies and for good
reasons to costume characters aren't
allowed to talk ever so they can't
refuse to hold someone's baby for a
picture but that doesn't mean that
they're happy about it most of the time
costume characters can't see all that
well they're tired dehydrated and feel
unqualified to hold a baby the parents
constantly hand their infants over to
them the party culture working at Disney
World means logging in super long hours
but it also means living a completely
upbeat lifestyle the party culture
amongst the disney world employees is
extremely wild and demanding many of the
cast members are college kids who work
hard and party harder so chances are
they might be a little tired from the
previous night's festivities but that's
never stopped them from putting on a
show or two wage differences getting
your hair done putting on makeup and
wearing awesome outfits is something
real life Disney characters take for
granted these face characters as they
call them are super popular intend to
make about $300 an hour more than
full-body characters these wage
differences often caused rivalry between
face characters and full-body characters
since the latter feel that their jobs
are much more challenging
after all they bake in a heavy sweaty
costume day in and day out stay in
character no matter what it's a
well-known fact that costume Disney
characters have to stay in character
it's the one golden rule and while it
might not seem like a life-threatening
one it can be at times when new
employees agree to wear house of mouse
apparel they sign away their right to
receive CPR while in costume this is
done to prevent kids from seeing their
heroes get unmasked
so basically employees need to stay in
character even if they're in critical
condition things get out of line believe
it or not but the happiest place on
earth isn't a stranger to fight every
single day tired people who have been
waiting in long lines get into screaming
matches with each other gasps get
outraged when less fortunate children
are allowed to cut lines and people get
arrested and thrown into Disney jail for
getting into physical altercations hard
to get easy to lose being accepted into
the good graces of the Walt Disney
family is
probably one of the hardest gigs to land
thousands of applicants apply to play
different Disney characters and only the
best make the cut but keeping your job
is a lot harder than getting it cast
members have been fired for eating
popcorn giving directions and calling in
sick you can't talk to us if you're
trying to find your way to Expedition
Everest the last person you should ask
for directions is a costume character
like goofy or Daffy Duck because well
they just won't talk to you they're not
allowed to period so don't take it
personally if Mickey Mouse gives you the
cold shoulder what's your favorite thing
about Walt Disney World
sound off in the comments thanks for
watching the things before you go make
sure to hit that subscribe button and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up we'll catch you next time